sur le tapis rouge une armée de
photographes et de journalistes ne
voulait rien manquer de l'arrivée du
réalisateur fait les falardeau et
découvre dettes de son nouveau film
j'adore ça pis là j'ai aussi un bouclier
qui s'appelle sigourney weaver qui prend
toute l'attention dont gréco aller aussi
donc moi je suis comme un petit garçon
j'adore il est très imaginatif et très
généreux et les est un très très bon
direct un médecin indique thürig ans et
je sais ya ce que mike savage eu lieu et
le récit biographique d'une aspirante
écrivaine qui devient en 1995
l'assistante de l'agent littéraire du
mythique écrivait américain jd salinger
quelques heures avant le tapis rouge
en conférence de presse le réalisateur
de gatineau a reçu d'une journaliste
un beau compliment il s'est fait dire
que son film montrait bien les rues de
new york alors que presque toutes les
scènes ont été filmées à montréal
j'étais très content quand une new
yorkaise s'est levé et que dit le fait
un très beau travail je vois souvent des
films à new york je viens de l'oeil on y
croit pop juste bien ces détournements
pour la crise ce livre fait les
falardeau est un réalisateur de
l'émotion qui laisse le champ libre aux
comédiennes cette expérience berlinoise
est importante pour philippe falardeau
dont le film se veut un hommage aux
femmes
j'ai clairement penser à ma fille en
tournant le film parce que tu vaux dire
comme parent à tes enfants à ta fille tu
peux faire ce que tu veux dans la vie
sont rencontrés des barrières qui sont
propres aux femmes
si votre rencontre qu'il y ait deux
poids deux mesures des fois après
philippe falardeau
ce sera au tour de la réalisatrice
québécoise anaïs barbeau-lavalette de
présenter samedi à la berlinale son
nouveau film elle sera en compétition
dans la catégorie génération elle
pourrait donc remporter un ours de
cristal ici oui j'ai depuis mai
radio-canada berlin